Ian actually purchased this book that's
been the subject of great controversy
and I have this tweet it's an I looked
up on Amazon this book is gay it's
called and Ian has purchased it right
here on the back it says this book is
for underlined everyone regardless of
gender sexual preference this book is
for anyone who's ever dared to wonder
this book is for you they sell it to 14
to 17 year olds on Amazon Amazon says
reading age is 14 to 17 you can see here
at the bottom yet in the book it it
teaches you and explains how to use
adult sex apps yeah explicitly so this
is this is what happens
you have
for whatever reason people on the left
either because they're over at
pedophiles or because over tribalists
will
will defend anything that the right
opposes
you end up with a book like this in
grade schools there's a teacher Who
provided this book to her middle
schoolers and they called the police on
her and she was removed and he and this
is what happens
a teacher provided this book to 10 to
middle schoolers the book shows pictures
of sex acts explains extremely
disgusting activities that would cause
serious illness like okay what people
need to understand is there are
activities that people engage in when it
comes to adult stuff that will injure
you and give you infections and diseases
and I'm talking about E coli and I don't
want to be gross but let's just I'm
gonna have to describe it for y'all we
try to keep it family friendly so
earmuffs for your kids but the book
describes consuming feces okay you you
can die from things like this wait are
you serious I didn't even know that was
in there I knew this was perverse I
didn't know that oh my gosh I'm I'm I'm
fairly certain I haven't seen that part
yet I'm fairly certain we talked about
that before I want to double check but
I'm pretty sure it talks about
yeah look maybe maybe and also maybe I
shouldn't be so surprised right because
there's a lot of perversity associated
with the this particular set of Life
Choices I I understand where why someone
might think this is a good idea because
like okay they're thinking kids don't
have enough sexual education we need to
prep these young kids that don't have
good families their lives ahead of time
it does confirm oh my God yeah here let
me see
dude that is sickening that is sickening
right and so jail what happens when uh
so to clarify though the the the
description is in the glossary
explaining what the ACT is and how to do
it so when parents see this stuff they
say hey
I don't want my kid reading that and
what happens you get uh that woman from
the majority report I'm a being like I
don't believe in censorship I think I'm
like should this be in school it's like
well I don't agree with censorship she
wants kids to read the new master of pet
house should be in schools and then the
conversation just changed after that
like she didn't say yes and she didn't
really say no I don't think I don't
remember exactly but it's a good point
do you want Pet house in schools do you
want like nudie magazines and for for 13
and 14 year olds to look at there's
pictures of nude there's a drawing of a
naked woman right in there I'm like page
what I don't know 188 or something like
that like explicit with arrows pointing
to the different private parts and like
that's what kids need to understand
private parts those are private those
are for you if someone ever messes with
your privacy in your private you tell an
adult you tell your parents like that is
this kind of is
but I'm coming from a different
generation man I didn't have the
internet until I was like 14. I didn't
see porn until I was 14. I didn't and
and for young kids that see slip on to
some of that at the age of six I don't
know it's a different reality for me how
you teach kids about this kind of thing
it even has a they they drew a picture
of Grindr oh my gosh like in the back uh
explains what a glory hole is on page
182 it says note Grindr is explically
for 18 and up and here's how it was used
right when it was brought up by the way
too she's like oh it's good and then you
guys were like well yes there's a
description of gay hookup apps and
someone was showing this a 10 year old
and she's like why do you get these
anecdotes
and it if if a child reads this and
comes in the back and comes to the
testing that explains consuming feces
you could die
why why would why would Amazon think a
14 to 17 year old should be reading
something like this and they make the
argument that oh kids have access to the
internet these days maybe they shouldn't
yeah exactly websites are supposed to
have blocks on them you're not supposed
to allow kids to be looking at this
stuff the idea that well no kids can see
other disgusting things in other
disgusting places so let's show them
disgusting things in their school where
I they ideally should be safe from this
kind of perversity I understand it even
explains amyl nitrate
wasn't that like bath salts or is that
like how you
what is that I'm not gonna get into it
all right it's it's it's a substance
used in uh
like crazy sex parties and all that
stuff we'll leave it at that yeah yeah
man on 182 they're like Grinders
explicitly this is what I don't get I
understand you want to tell a kid ahead
of time things they got to watch out
here are the phone numbers in the back
of organizations to call to get more
information and more access but there's
an advocacy holy there's a difference
between warning children about what's to
come and showing them how to do the
things they're not supposed to do right
when it says this is for 18 and up this
this app but here's how exactly how you
use it you upload a photo and it says
you upload a photo like it tells them
you do it you do this thing I'm I'm I'm
not going to read it piece by piece it's
just so disturbing note grinder also has
an age minimum of 18 years old it's in
bold then the next paragraph how sex
acts were or apps sex apps work upload a
tiny pic of yourself to the app like
it's for 18 year olds you don't tell
them how to do it yeah also the idea
that you can get away with something
like that in a book that's being
marketed to children by simply saying oh
you have to be 18 or up well this stuff
is in schools it's being shown to
Children Amazon's selling it to children
as young as 14 years old there was a
teacher who was showing it to 10 year
olds and the idea that you would give
somebody a guide on how to use these
hookup apps is if it's rocket science
and you need a guide to know how to log
in you're clearly directing these kids
to do this like you're clearly directing
them to do this
so sick so so the main point was
Amazon says 14 to 17 year olds
what do you think would happen if you
went to a playground with a bunch of 14
year olds and started teaching them how
to use grinder jail you'd be arrested as
you should be yep right but there but
but when it comes to what they're doing
in schools it's all protected and then
when we ask a simple question
to a leftist who comes on this show
comes on the culture War podcast why is
why how hard is it for them to be like
no I get it those books shouldn't be in
school
instead they say I don't believe in
censorship so allow it and I'm like what
yeah no but if you wanted to have a
Bible in a school library right it's so
funny how two-faced they are right and
it's clear that they're not interested
in either Free Speech or combating
censorship because none of them were
saying that schools not being able to
teach creationism meant that Christians
didn't have free speech all the
arguments they're making for this
perverse nonsense are arguments that
they obviously didn't make in favor of
people teaching their children their
values about the Christian faith they
weren't saying well you know when kids
get old enough they're going to learn
about Christianity anyway so we should
tell them about it now like that's kept
as far away from public schools as
possible but guidebooks that teach
children how to eat feces and use gay
hookup apps are not kept away from
schools for some reason and when someone
tries to keep it away from schools we
call them a tyrant that's where our
culture's at right now parents called
the police on a teacher who showed this
to their kids to the great to the to the
middle school kids good for them yeah
yeah this is why Target's getting hit
getting getting stuck drop this is why
Bud Light suffering because these
companies they're just marching along
like don't know don't care we're just
gonna do whatever we're told to do and
parents are saying no right now we we've
had enough of this stuff there was that
remember
um the uh Nick marks the the gamer when
he was like leave the kids alone and
they went nuts on them yep and uh I
guess what the sentiment was he recently
became a father
yup now you get it now you're like how
dare you show my children these things
and parents started seeing it and now
there's a backlash I think this could be
the Dem one of the Democrats biggest
weaknesses Trump was recently in a rally
and he was like you know I could talk
his I'm paraphrasing we said something
like I talk about lowering taxes nobody
cares I talk about culture War stuff
everybody starts cheering yes
because taxes are like a boring thing we
deal with periodically and try and
figure out the right number typically we
want to go down everybody wants it to go
down but right now we're dealing with an
existential threat targeting children
this has got people riled up like crazy
yeah and and again rightfully so I'm
curious what what path forward do you
see here what do you think family should
be doing what do you think it's it's
possible to do within the guidelines of
the law also as a lawyer I mean who who
can be sued who can charges be pressed
against for these kinds of things look I
mean there's a lot of parents who are
stepping up across the country who are
are saying no more and doing things like
I mean look if you're a parent and you
have a teacher showing your kids
explicit material you should I think in
in under the right circumstances
reported to law enforcement but you also
have all kinds of other ways that you
can do things you can sue the school
district you can get the materials
demand that the materials are removed
from the libraries I mean just simple
steps showing up going to school board
meetings showing up talking to your
teachers talking to your principals
because you know ultimately you know we
are in that place I think as a culture
as a country where it is where the
societal inflection point where you know
which direction do we go do we tolerate
more of this because that's what we're
going to get if we don't stop it right
or do we say no enough is enough and so
a lot of folks are are are using
um courts using courts of public opinion
to advance the ball and try to defend
not not I would say even conservative
values I mean they are conservative
values but just traditional American
values human values things that have
been understood for millennia
and that now are just being uh tolerated
uh like that book that book is
disgusting it has no place in a school
there's a
Snopes highlighted a chap uh uh a a
section from the book I want to find it
in the book who put the notes in the
book was that wasn't character that oh
okay so maybe maybe the notes show uh no
there's uh is that it
how to argue with Sodom and Gomorrah
yeah so he and I were going back and
forth between the show he was like
reading the supposed like these
objections to the Bible and they were
all very weak they're all very bad and
also objections the Islamic teaching on
it the book instructs people young kids
I'm gonna say kids because it's sold to
14 to 70 year olds the book instructs
kids how to argue uh against religion
Christianity Islam I want to talk about
gay sex so right at the uh beginning of
the chapter that talks talking about sex
it says this chapter is about sex
therefore it has sex in it well duh if
you're a younger reader and you feel you
aren't ready for the finer details of
same-sex pairings then simply skip this
whole chapter however before you do
I'd like to remind you that we taught
you all about straight sex when you were
11 years old during sixth grade the fact
that they didn't also teach you what
same-sex couples do is nothing less than
institutionalized homophobia straight
sex was presented as the norm to make
five percent of the population feel
abnormal is there something icky about
gay sex is there something wrong with it
I challenge any politician to discuss
this with me I will ruin them this
chapter is simply all the stuff teachers
should be saying if they want to be
inclusive of people with same-sex
feelings two things I want to point out
the first sentence the first couple of
sentences in the introduction is if you
feel you aren't ready skip this
it then says however before you do I
want to remind you meaning
if you're not ready consider why you
should read it anyway thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time